[Music]
okay
e3
yeah we've already faced this move and
uh you guys should remember that our
response to this is d5 okay so we're
very likely facing
a hippo which is g3 e3 and then b3 d3
and the best thing to do against all of
these defenses is to start by occupying
the center
and if if you'll remember
i introduced a really effective
setup against the hippo
a couple of games back i think it was in
the speed run basically what you do is
you play knight f6
and then you play the move pawn c6 i
really really like playing c6 in these
positions essentially creating a pawn
chain
so that the bishop
well to use my favorite expression bites
on granite
and then this
pawn triangle like in the london many
openings it creates a square on d6 on
which you can put your bishop
now you might ask well what about this
knight this knight can't go on can't go
to c6 anymore
well where does the knight on b8 go
ultimately obviously you should
understand that it goes to d7 but where
is it heading
as a final destination in order to
facilitate a kingside attack
so we'll start with knight bd7
it's not going to c5 if you go to c5 you
kind of walk into d4 that knight on c5
doesn't do anything
yeah so
human ftw
spells it out correctly we go knight f8
knight g6 kind of right lopez style
and our opponent is yeah it's playing
instantly c3d4
now what is this knight doing exactly
well it is
located on the king side so there's all
sorts of sacrifices in the future and
also as we're going to see it makes
the pawn storm h5h4 a lot more effective
so what should we do now
how should we
how should we answer the move d4
given that we are going to attack on the
king's side
so given that we're going to attack on
the king's side
the best thing to do is to close the
center of course to play e4 and probably
he's gonna go c4 but the move c4 doesn't
really do anything the pawn on d5 is
where very well protected okay now what
should we do
now we need to go
right our opponent has barely completed
his development
essentially everything is in place now
one very common misconception in such
positions is that we have to develop our
bishop we don't our bishop is perfectly
satisfied being on c8 if we need it
later we'll develop it we just we don't
need to bring our bishop out just to say
that we developed our pieces let's go
let's go h5 we want to checkmate him
c4 this move doesn't accomplish anything
pawn on d5 is perfectly well protected
let's go h4
we're already on the verge of delivering
checkmate that's how quick that's how
quick this is okay so cd we obviously
want to recapture knight c3 again does
this move accomplish anything specific
the answer to that is no it doesn't
it doesn't
we want to be careful
in terms of how we approach
uh
the opening of the king side
so automatically playing the move h
takes g3
that's a double-sided sword because hg3
white might play f takes g3
and then white opens up the f file for
his rook so
we have to have a follow up in mind if
we're playing h63 and very often
it's actually a good idea not to hurry
so let's think about this for a second
hg3 fg3 in that position we really want
to play them of knight shoot for right
well that's a very tempting move it
attacks h2 to taxi t3 what's wrong with
knight chief iv in that position what's
wrong with knight iv in that resulting
position there is something that move
and it's the same thing that's wrong
with knight four here
yeah it gives up the pawn on d5 now you
might say well why is that pawn
important well it's a center pawn and if
the d5 pawn falls then the e4 pawn is
also likely to fall and that messes
things up it complicates things so let's
make one prophylactic move just one
and uh with this move we
we make it so much easier for ourselves
to attack on the king's side just go
bishop b6 this also happens to complete
the development but that's not the
important part important thing about
this move is that it defends the d5 pawn
and it makes it possible to go knight g4
in the future
and these are the moves people don't
like playing when they're attacking
okay so what is the idea of this move
well maybe he wants knight b5 but knight
p5 we can always drop our bishop back to
b8
so now i think the time has come for us
to
to start
operating on the king side
h takes g3 and knight g4
now the interesting thing that you might
notice
is that the bishop is overloaded here it
is defending d5 it is defending the
knight
and i'm very impressed that he found
knight 65 quickly
but i saw this
i saw this and i had planned what did i
plan what did i plan on this position
what can we do because the knight is
hanging
if we can move this knight away with
tempo then
well white's going to have two hanging
pieces at the same time no no no knight
takes you through blunders the knight
what are you guys saying knight takes
you three blunders the knight
knight takes h2 however is a better move
because it attacks the rook and if the
rook moves we take the knight
this is not entirely clear cut because
the knight can return to c3 he goes
knight f4 which is also a good move by
the way
um
okay well what should we do now well
let's take the rook
knight takes f1
and now we're just up in exchange and
we're conti we're still attacking let's
trade on f4
let's get rid of that knight he takes f4
and now our advantage has been converted
we've converted our
um
our tactical advantage our attack into a
material advantage an extra exchange and
now we have to demonstrate proper uh
conversion technique
yeah so f5
f5 is one way to do it but it does allow
the move d5 which opens up the bishop's
diagonal so we have to handle this very
very carefully
we have to handle this very very
carefully
this is not so easy actually this is
this is not easy at all
in fact
let me think about this for a second i i
need to think what do we want to do here
yeah let's go five
let's go f5 let's defend the e4 i feel
like this is the most important pawn to
defend
i i feel like this is the pawn we want
to defend because it also puts the
bishop out of commission d5
this guy's good
okay well we have to move our bishop
back so let's move it back to f7
he's going to take this pawn and that's
what i was contemplating is it worth
giving that pawn away and i concluded
that yes it is it is worth giving that
pawn away
it is worth giving that pawn away
because at least we have the e4 pawn
which is a big big pawn
i'm hoping he goes okay goes bishop h6
that's a mistake that's a losing move
that is a losing move
now anytime you have a king on g1 that
is this week
you need to be hyper aware
of every possibility every opportunity
uh to get to that king on both sides of
the board
not just on the king side but also on
the queen side any time the pawn moves
away from f2 it opens up this diagonal
if you're aware of that then it's a lot
easier to find the mobile is the move
bishop c5 check
no well it's not because there's a rook
on c1 that's guarding that's where but
can we do anything else on that diagonal
yes we can we can play queen b6 check
forcing the king onto the h file
but what sits on the h file whether it's
bishop on h6 it's undefended we can drop
the rook back to h8 and pick up the
bishop
yeah simple
uh simple sequence we got lucky there
bishop d4 was not actually that clear
so my my
technique there was a little bit sloppy
but it does the job and i'll talk about
it more after the game why exactly it
was sloppy what should we have done
instead
no rook g6 doesn't trap the bishop
because of bishop g5 it's better to go
rook h8 that's a pin
oh thank you for the thank you for the
10 dono appreciate it
the question is how do we convert this
advantage as quickly as possible
and so well the answer to that is we
have a knight on h2 our opponent has a
knight on h2 that knight is very
vulnerable we want to double on the h
file well what's stopping us it's the
king we can just move the king up to e7
and then
slide the rook on over to h8 rook a to
h8
we're not afraid of bishop take c4 here
white is running out of pieces our king
is perfectly safe in the center
okay and if we want to win the game with
the flourish there is actually forced
mate here
if we want to win the game with a
flourish
we can change up the move order just a
little bit as soon as the queen leaves
e2
for some reason my eyes are drawn to the
f2 square and if the bishop is gone from
g2 right the pattern recognition starts
circulating
and if you've solved enough tactics this
is something you should see quickly you
take on h2 then you bring the other rook
to a chain and then after the bishop
blocks you you swoop into f2 with
checkmate
easy enough i mean that's that's very
straightforward stuff check
he's gotta cover with the bishop because
the queen covers g1
and then once we play queen f2 check the
game is over the king has to drop back
we take the bishop and it's mate
we can even pre-move rock h3
why did i go to e7 instead of d7 there
was no major reason
the only reason was that if we went to
d7 we would be susceptible to a later
check on b5 that's literally the only
consideration that i had
of course both moves are equally winning
yeah white played well i mean i don't
think that he he was played quite weird
very fast but saw some tactics yeah i
mean
it's not unlikely that he sits it out
okay
so e3d5 again i don't recommend e5 in
this position because this is kind of a
reversed french with an extra tempo
okay so e5 knight f6 c6 one of many
possible setups but this is how i played
against the hippo
thus far in the speedrun you put the
bishop between the pawns
b3
and bd7 and then you walk your knight
around through f82 g6 notice that i'm
not actually castling and the reason i'm
not castling is because i already know
that i'm going to push my h button so
keeping the king in the center is quite
important for that
now is it a mistake to castle no i mean
you can castle you can play it
positionally nothing wrong with that
it's just that i was in an aggressive
mood this game c3 our opponent is
obviously not playing this well d4 is an
ideal scenario for black
now generally yeah you can you can
absolutely castle queen side here yeah
you absolutely can castle queenside but
keeping the king in the center is
perfectly safe given that the center is
closed
um
okay so knight d2 h5 now by the way
generally if you're white in these
positions probably white should go f3
this is the lesser evil everything sucks
here
but this sucks a little bit less because
at least it opens up the center and you
can try for e4 here it's probably
already too late because we're already
going h4
but maybe this is a way to mix things up
just a little bit the thing is of course
f3 from a positional standpoint is very
bad at weakening z4 it creates a
backward pawn on e3 so if knight takes
f3
we could contemplate going queen e7
hitting the pawn and then you know
entrenching a knight on the outpost e4
uh but if he doesn't do this you know
what happens is what happened in the
game which is that we have a free hand
and we just you know crash through on
the h file
so this was a good move our opponent
played very very well this stretch okay
so bishop b6 reinforcing the pawn
and after rook c1 here i think i didn't
play accurately i think maybe hg and
knight 4 was not the best conversion
you know i think the best move here
might have actually been queen d7 with
the idea of going bishop h3 this is the
traditional way of exploiting the atrial
as you know
as you know
i i think we can you can check the
engine but i think queen d7 is probably
the best i just don't see how white
defense against it
should he have gone h4 yeah so that's a
good question you know what happens if
fight goes h4 well in this case it's two
weakening i think if white goes h4
we can even consider taking on h4 but
the best thing is to set that up with
knight shoe for knight e4
uh followed by knight takes h4 i'm
pretty sure
i mean you're gonna sack on h4 and it's
gonna be totally overwhelming so like c4
uh knight takes h4
obviously if g takes h4
queen takes h4 as mate on h2 and rookie
1 bishop h2 is the fastest way to mate
if king f1 then queen takes f2 king h1
the knight takes f2 both are made
otherwise made on h2
well white can't avoid an attack because
white played terribly in the opening fh3
uh who can tell me what black's a pro uh
correct approach here is should we play
h4 tr slight trick question
or maybe not just think about it should
black play h4 here's that a good idea
i think i know what you guys are going
to be thinking and this is a very
instructive moment
so the answer is yes
why is the answer yes so after g4 there
are two distinct ways that you can
exploit this position one is winning on
the spot one is just something for your
general attacking arsenal
in general
because g4 weakens this diagonal you can
set up a battery with bishop b8
now a very important subtlety bishop b8
here is better than bishop c7 who can
explain to me why
why is bishop c7 an inaccuracy i have
asked this question before we've had
this before on the speed run so this is
a review
this is not the best by the way i'm just
saying this so you know that this idea
exists
bishop a3 bishop a3 stop screen d6 and
after bishop b8 you have an additional
battery square on c7
very good
so these subtleties are important and
they're pretty easy to look at if you
have the right mentality but knight
takes g4 is the move that wins on the
spot h takes g4 and now you just shove
the h1 down the board h3
h2 check
and among other things i think the
fastest path you can play queen h4 queen
h3 and that's mate you can also give a
knight h4 check
and probably just smash through with
bishop takes g4 and queen d7 and this is
mate
this is easy mate so but the
most important thing here is to know
this idea of sacking on g4 and then
going h3 h2
this is not always winning but in this
position white is so passive that it's
totally crushing
so just remember this idea going h4
inducing g4 and then sacking in order to
get that h button rolling
we had this idea no no we did have this
idea definitely
so nothing helps here
but again i think hg knight g4 was a
little hasty initially i did miss knight
takes d5 and this complicates matters
because once we lose our center things
get a little bit more more hairy
okay knight takes h2 fortunately this
move exists otherwise i think black is
in trouble
um knight f4 i mean that's as good of a
move as any knight takes f1 now if white
had played knight takes e6 here
who can tell me what black would have
done what is our best move in this
position with black
see dallas thank you for the sub thanks
everyone for all the subs and support
much appreciated
if we had taken the night with the
bishop his queen would have taken our
knight
very good i take c3 and termetzo
both of us are attacking each other's
queen
knight takes d knight takes d1 and very
importantly
otherwise white would have been
attacking two pieces at the same time
but here we can actually take the bishop
which is
quite crucial
um and still this is not so clear-cut i
mean knight takes d6 check happens
this is maybe not so clear-cut
because our knight is in is in some
trouble white's got an initiative
despite being down in exchange
so you know maybe
wow maybe
hmm
yeah maybe we should play f66 but then
yeah f takes c6 maybe even better
actually
and queen takes f1
maybe maybe i move like queen g5 hitting
e3
yeah this i think is is the biggest path
to an advantage because we we preserve a
big attack on the king
no but i don't think white had a defense
once we played tribe i think why this
played this so passively that after h5
objectively speaking there was no
defense not all attacks have you cannot
defend against everything if you play
terribly the attack is going to be
decisive
okay so e takes f4 and here
somewhere around here i feel like i also
played inaccurately f5 d5 so initially i
had a really cool idea that
unfortunately doesn't work and you guys
will tell me why it doesn't work
so
anytime and i told this to my students
all the time anytime a pawn is pushed in
the center
you have to consider which squares are
weakened and which diagonals are now
open so as soon as d5 was played the
first thing i thought about is queen b6
check that's the first move that
occurred to me now unfortunately it
doesn't work because white has bishop d4
but that doesn't mean that this idea
doesn't work and then i had the idea
well what if we try to put the bishop on
the diagonal
well bishop c5 doesn't work either right
where it takes c5 but
then i had another idea which is that
well why don't we get this bishop
somewhere where it's defended such as b6
and so i came up with the move bishop c7
that would have been a really sick move
because after d takes e6 bishop b6 it's
almost checkmate because d4 is now
protected
but what is the tactical flaw of the
move bishop c7
and i think black is probably still
winning at the end of this it's just a
little bit less clear this doesn't
achieve what i wanted to achieve no 93
but should be six anyway
rook takes c7 is the problem
after queen c7de white actually ends up
having three pieces for the two rooks
which is which is not the worst thing in
the world
and uh if we give a check on b6 then
once again why does bishop d4
so i didn't want to allow that and so
that's the reason why i decided
ultimately to drop the bishop back
okay so here white made the decisive
mistake bishop page takes bishop d4
would have i think preserved
some chances although after bishop takes
d5 of course
um black is up a full exchange and the
king is weak we are winning although now
here there's queen h5 track
so our king is
yeah yeah no sorry bishop d5 walks into
queen h5 check so we shouldn't take this
pawn
we shouldn't take this pawn we should
probably play queen d7 first yeah yeah
we should play queen d7 first to defend
f5 so that bishop takes d5 is now
possible
and if he reroutes his knight then he
drops the g3 pawn which is big
no queen i could think queen d4 is bad
because it at a minimum it allows a
queen trade which is in our favor since
we're up on exchange
so yeah
so the way that i played here with with
uh
the early knight g4 is not ideal but it
did the job and ultimately the
point to extract from this game is this
h5h4 concept remembering uh that you can
often induce g4
and then sac on g4 and these various
attacking techniques
can really help you play a smooth game
all right
[Music]
you